[Music]
guys we're at the table and today we
were at the rid table to talk about sex
yes that's Jada pinkett-smith and
daughter Willow talking SVX on their
Facebook watch series at read table talk
oh the red table is a place of testimony
you know and a place where we get to
share our story share our experiences
and get to really talk and spill our
truth in a very wrong way the ladies
were joined by Jada's mom and willows
best friend for the candid conversation
my grandmother taught me about self
pleasuring because she wanted me to know
that that pleasure was from me and she
taught me at 9:00
Jada got real about her experience with
self-pleasure shocking the table with
her revelations I gave myself multiples
first Oh
multiple orgasms yes I did I was really
into it at one point just because I was
in an exploration state and I was AB
staining from men oh yeah and I actually
think I went through kind of an
addiction to with oh yeah after you yeah
the actress also discussed losing her
virginity my first sexual experience was
amazing he revealed that she has a sixth
sense for knowing when her kids lose
theirs
I knew the night-sun nice Jaden lost his
virginity just the energy of them that
made you know that they had sex yeah it
was it was like a new their innocence
was gone
damn God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]